these aren't the sexiest stories but
they're hugely important gerrymandering
redistricting the upcoming 2020 census
voter ID and voter suppression this
stuff really matters for elections in
the future and so we have to talk about
it and I told you earlier this week that
the Pennsylvania gerrymandering that was
done by Republicans after the 2010
census is finally being cut off by the
Pennsylvania Supreme Court upheld by the
Federal Supreme Court good news but
remember that they did the
gerrymandering in 2011 based on the 2010
census and it helped Republicans control
the congressional districts in
Pennsylvania in the 2012 election the
2014 election and the 2016 election it
takes a long time to fix this stuff so
we should be doing everything we can to
prevent it from happening in the first
place the next census is in 2020 I've
told you about it a number of times it
will be used for redistricting in 2021
and it will be used as early as in the
2022 election and this is huge
because if Trump wins re-election in
2020 it will be even more important to
prevent Republicans from using
gerrymandering to clean up and pick up
even more seats in the House in 2022
if Trump loses in 2020 we're not going
to want Republicans to be able to use
the gerrymandering of district maps to
make gains in 2022 the way that very
often the party out of the White House
does in midterm elections so this is a
big deal
and the National Democratic
redistricting committee met a couple of
days ago and they announced that they
are targeting 12 states that they think
could prevent the crazy redistricting
that has taken place under Republican
rule Republicans actually have such
control nationally over redistricting
that this is not even an attempt from
Democrats to take over control they just
want to eke out just enough influence
that they can force Republicans to
negotiate with them a little bit more
fairly
so what Democrats want to do is go after
nine gubernatorial races 20 legislative
chambers two ballot initiatives
and to down ballot races and they also
have eight other states on their watch
list and it's important to understand
what's going on here because I've said
before that in 2018 all 435 House seats
are up for re-election and that's true
I'm not talking about that here what I'm
talking about here are statewide races
where lots of gerrymandering activity
actually happens and that's where
Republicans do really really well so
we're talking about governorships which
are mostly controlled by Republican in
the United States right now I'm talking
about state houses which are mostly
controlled by Republicans right now and
things are actually so bad in some
states that the goal isn't even to take
control of the state either by winning
the governorship or a majority in the
State House the goal in some of these
places because it's so upside down in
favor of Republicans is let's get
Democrats just enough seats to be able
to do a little bit of negotiating and
that's how bad it is that the bar is set
so low for what would still be a huge
improvement for Democrats at the state
level and given the option like if we
could choose okay a Democrat takes over
the governor's seat or Democrats as a
group take over a state legislature the
governorship is definitely simpler since
that's one seat that can block
gerrymandering in that particular state
but it's just not realistic in a lot of
states and we're linking on the YouTube
video description for the story to the
article that lays this out and I think
it is important to think about this to
understand where to donate your money
right if you're not the Koch brothers or
Sheldon Adelson or whoever you have
limited political contributions that you
can make so you want to consider as many
factors as possible in thinking about
where that money should go some of us
might just on a whim say well I'll just
donate exactly where I am I'll donate to
the Senate race in my state if it's up
in 2018 I'll donate to whoever I want to
be my representative in the US House of
Representatives and I'll vote down
ballot for example
when it's election day consider that you
might have a bigger impact if you were
able to help by donating maybe instead
if in if your district is safe maybe you
decide to donate to a Democrat running a
race for governor in some other state
for example right I'm not saying you
definitely want to do that but you need
to understand where will your limited
number of dollars that you contribute to
politics have the biggest impact and
gerrymandering and the Census and
redistricting impact and influence
politics in so many ways that we've got
to be cognizant of what the impact is
going to be big picture beyond just I'll
donate to my local City Council and
state Senate see because this is a
really really big thing and it could
shape we saw what happened with the 2010
census three elections before courts
decided that was not good and this was
unconstitutional with redistricting
let's prevent it from going wrong in the
first place I'm on twitter at des Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show boy do we have a fantastic program
for you today today's episode of the
david pakman show is made possible in
part by brilliant you watch the David
Pakman show or listen to the David
Pakman show
so clearly you're interested in politics
and in following what's going on in the
world and the economy the environment
but what's crucial to understand is that
almost everything we talk about on this
show is sort of on the foundation of
math science and philosophy and keeping
up with the news is one thing but you're
never really fully equipped to
understand political issues and have
debates with people until you've
actually developed a more complete
understanding of how the world works and
how these issues work at the most
fundamental level and brilliant is one
of the most effective and enjoyable ways
to do that that I've ever come across
you can learn hands-on about statistics
crime climate science energy it's a long
list and you can get started right now
by signing up for free at brilliant org
slash David Pakman first 200 people who
visit brilliant org slash David Pakman
we'll also get 20% off an annual premium
and membership check it out sign up for
free today at brilliant org slash David
Pakman